hey this is presh talwalkar
find the pattern in the following set of
numbers
eight eight zero nine is equal to six
seven one one one is equal to zero
six six six six is equal to four
seven six five two is equal to one
three three six eight is equal to three
nine three one three is equal to one
one zero zero eight is equal to four
nine eight eight seven is equal to five
and one one five five is equal to zero
based on this pattern what is two zero
two one equal to
for a bit of clarification the equal
sign is not used as an equivalence
relationship this is actually used as a
function that's mapping these four
digits into a unique answer
you are also not trying to figure out
every single possible pattern which will
fit this relationship
instead think of it like breaking a code
you are trying to figure out what the
other person might have had as their
code and you're trying to figure out
what 2021
would map to
various versions of this problem have
been spread online and gone viral
some people say only a genius can solve
it
other people say that preschoolers can
solve this in five minutes computer
programmers can solve it in one hour
and people with higher education
well why don't you try and figure it out
for yourself
a version of this problem was also used
in a mathematical olympiad for
eight-year-olds
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try and when you're ready
keep watching to learn how to solve this
problem
[Music]
so what is the pattern
you want to figure out the number of
holes or the number of closed paths of a
number
so the number
8809 has exactly 6 holes or six closed
paths
thus eight eight zero nine maps to the
number six
we can apply this pattern and see it
fits all of the other observations we're
given seven one one one
has no holes in the number so it maps to
zero
six six six six this has exactly four
holes and it maps to four
now on seven six five two there's
exactly one hole so it maps to one
three three six eight has three holes
so this fits and we can verify this
pattern for all of the other
observations we're given
so we want to solve what 2 0 2 1 maps to
there's exactly one hole in this number
therefore 2 0 2 1 is equal to 1
and that's the answer
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on youtube see you next
episode of mind your decisions where we
solve the world's problems one video at
a time
you